[MUSIC PLAYING]
RON CARUCCI: So thanks
for being here today.
I hope this is a meaningful
conversation for you.
How many of you,
by a show of hands,
have aspirations of
some kind to elevate
your role at some
point in your career
and lead more people than
you're leading today?
Great.
So this will be super
relevant to you, I hope,
to avoid some of the pitfalls
we found in our research.
So I want to do three things--
talk about the data we collected
and how we got the research
and why, how it is that people
who rise up to bigger jobs
and organizations, some
seem to thrive, and then
talk with you in a
little bit of Q&A
about how it is you are
thinking about applying it here.
So a bunch of years ago--
our firm works on large, crazy,
transformational projects
with our clients.
And a bunch of
years ago, we were
working with an organization
during which one
of the young leaders who
had been part of the effort
was super-high-potential,
seen as very competent,
people enjoy working with him.
Everybody saw a long,
promising career for him.
At the end of the project,
he was offered the chance
to take on a much
broader assignment
for the organization in this new
world we had just transformed.
Nobody was surprised.
Everybody assumed,
oh, he'll do great.
About nine months later, I
saw his name on the caller ID,
and I was excited.
I assumed, oh, he's
calling to tell me
about all the great
progress they've made
and how things are going.
But sadly, he was calling
to tell me he'd been fired
and that he needed help
getting another job.
I barely had time to recover
from that conversation, two
hours later the CEO of
this large multinational
gazillion-dollar organization,
who's our client, called
to also let me know
they'd let him go,
and that he was a bit angry,
implying-- more than implying--
that some of the
responsibility for his failure
was mine, for not
better preparing him.
That didn't feel good.
I was devastated.
I couldn't imagine, how could
we have possibly misjudged
his potential that much?
Every nine-box, eight-box,
six-box, whatever grid
you used, he was off the charts.
How could somebody suddenly
go from being in one level,
being the next coming,
to suddenly being
a disaster in nine months?
That made no sense.
I asked if we might come
back into the organization
to see if we could learn
what could have gone wrong.
That short investigation
we went back in and did
led us to a 10-year
longitudinal study
of more than 2,700 leaders.
And what we found out was,
painfully, that more than 50%
of those that take on
broader assignments
in their organizations fail
in their first 18 months.
That young leader was
just another statistic.
We thought, gosh,
we can do better!
I don't ever want another phone
call like that in my career
again.
So we began digging and
digging and digging to find,
why is it-- for
more than 20 years,
we've known this statistic.
This is not-- the
recruiters love it,
because it's an
annuity for them.
But short of that,
why is that OK?
50%, right?
That's a crap shoot.
Why is it OK that the carnage
of families that have relocated
and people who had promising
ideas and opportunities
that organizations were
hoping to capitalize,
that half of them go
sideways is reasonable?
That just seemed completely
unacceptable to us.
So we began to go digging.
And the scary thing we
found in the research
was, when we found out how many
landmines organizations put
in the way of people
on their way up,
it's a wonder any
of them succeed.
I couldn't wait to find out
what the other 50% were doing
to manage to traverse those.
I went back to the
CEO and I said,
I will apologize and
take responsibility
for all the landmines I did
not prepare him to face.
You need to take responsibility
for putting them there,
because they're so unnecessary.
So what I want to spend
time today talking about
that we found in this study of
2,700 leaders, 1,800 of which
were set aside as at least
bordering on exemplary,
we also isolated 100
of them in mid-ascent
to see if we could sort of watch
in slow-mo what was happening
across this elevation season.
Whether it was to an executive
role or to middle management,
from wherever they were, what
was going on on the way up,
and what caused some to
stick the landing, and some
to faceplant?
To hopefully avoid those.
So there's three parts
I want to chat about.
One is, what's the weird things
that happen on the way up?
Why is there this
altitude sickness?
Right, you get to
a higher altitude,
you can barely breathe
as you land there.
And then the great
news in the data
was, in fact, that
as we dug into,
what were the other half doing
that made them just thrive?
And it turns out there were
four recurring patterns.
I had the research team
do 99 regression analyses.
And they finally said, enough.
It's not going to change.
The same four recurring
patterns, over and over, that
set apart those that succeeded.
The problem was--
and that's where
we'll spend the most
of our time today.
The problem was, the data said
you had to do all four well.
So people who did three
of the four brilliantly
were in the failure group.
So the reason I kept going
back to do more analysis
is I didn't want to have to say
you had to do all four well.
I wanted to say three of the
four is OK, but it's not.
So we'll talk about
what those four are.
The great news was,
these weren't four--
like, some weird
genetic misalignments
that caused this superhuman
power in these folks.
These were basic
capabilities that they
had acquired and learned.
So the good news is
they're learnable.
The best time to
learn them is not
when you hit your first senior
director job or your first vice
president job.
The best time to
learn them is now.
So here's just
some of the things
we found that were a
little bit shocking to us.
69% of the people
in our research
said, we were not
prepared for the roles.
I'm sure, in your department,
that wouldn't be the case.
But in other companies,
that's what people told us.
76% said that all of
the formal development
efforts they had undergone
did not prepare them
for the challenges they faced.
They had great
theories and models
and read some
interesting articles,
but what they faced
in the challenges
was never covered in any of
their learning developments.
And most of them
had no coaching.
Most of them had no preparation
work before, and none of them--
it was in the 80% of
what they had afterwards.
67% of them struggled to let go.
So they took-- as
they escalated,
they took the work with them.
One of the interesting things
about the notion of power,
we studied, how do people
handle the notion of power?
And these days, that's a
pretty important conversation.
60% of them felt like impostors.
They felt like people
ascribed more power to them
than they actually felt
they had themselves.
And so they struggled
to reconcile
feeling like they're going to,
at some point, find me out.
So you can see here, these
are not pretty stats, right?
This begins to give
a picture for why
it is that so many promising
young professional aspiring
leaders are arriving in
positions that they're not
ready for.
We can do better.
We absolutely can do better.
So one of the metaphors we use
in the early part of the book
is this is very much
like wing-walking.
Long before you
were born, people
in the early part of the 20th
century would actually get up--
both for aerial
entertainment, but also
to learn how to refuel planes--
would walk across the wing.
And of course, the rule
number one in wing-walking
is never let go of
the strut you're
holding onto until
you have a firm
grip on the strut
you're going to,
because that doesn't go well.
Well, too many wing-walkers
either let go too soon,
or they couldn't let go.
They became paralyzed.
And they could never
cross the wing.
But both types of failures
happen on the way up.
Leaders get too
confident and too cocky,
and they just fly up there
without taking lessons
with them, or they freeze,
and they get paralyzed
in the terror of a
different orientation
and a different
view of the world.
So here are some of the--
five of the numbers of things
we found on the way up.
How many of you have been
involved here at Google
in interviewing
people for other jobs?
Now, I know a little something
about your selection process.
You actually do a decent
job of asking people
for evidence-based
behavioral events
of their accomplishments.
But many organizations still
interview people using what?
Their resume.
And what is it they
do with the resume?
This is the part where you talk.
They go through it.
Right.
And then you hear eerie
statements like this.
Wow, look at those great apps
you built at your company!
That's what we need!
Or, my gosh, look at this
incredible sophisticated coding
and engineering work you've
done at your company.
That's what we need!
Or, wow, look at
these great brands
you were part of building.
That's what we need!
What's happening
in that statement?
You're setting
somebody up to fail,
because here's the
message you're sending.
You're saying to them,
you have a formula.
You have a recipe
for success that we
would like you to bring here.
How many of you have watched
people enter the organization--
maybe not here at Google,
but maybe other companies--
and have it not go well?
And what's the term we use
after about six or seven months?
They're not a good fit.
Right?
Which is code for all kinds
of things, usually not
the issue of a fit.
It's a failure of context.
Right, this person failed
to read the tea leaves.
They come in with this mythical
mandate to prove themselves.
You told me this
is what you wanted.
Right?
So they take the bait,
and they come in,
whether they've risen up and
got hired by somebody inside,
or came in from the outside,
they have a mandate.
So they took it seriously.
Well, the mandate is
devoid of context, right?
I don't want your
success formula slapped
on my organization.
I'm assuming there
is some wisdom you
can bring with you
from those experiences
that you can contextualize here.
But if you fail to learn me
before you try and change me,
that's not going to go well.
So from the very beginning,
many of these leaders
with promising talent
and otherwise important
contributions failed because
they had this mandate
that they believed
they had to follow,
that they should
have never followed.
Well, so let's play this out.
So what happens when
I'm trying to slap
on this formula of success
you told me you wanted,
and it's not working?
What have you seen happen
to the person who's
not being able to get traction?
What do you see in them?
They get frustrated.
And why are they frustrated?
They're not making impact.
And they were told
to make impact.
So my first conclusion about
why I'm not making impact
is usually not, it must be me.
Right?
It's usually you didn't--
I go to the hiring manager.
You didn't tell me
it was this bad.
Or, you didn't tell me
they were this resistant.
And so now my diagnosis
of what's not working
becomes an indictment
and a judgment
of why they can't get this
brilliant thing that I brought.
Right?
What happens when those
around this person
feel indicted by their presence?
And usually it sounds like this.
Well, at Apple, we--
or, well, at Microsoft,
what we did was--
and what are people
saying in the hallway?
If I hear one more story
about where they came from--
right?
So now, the minute
they start talking,
when I was-- that's it.
I've tuned out.
What comes next
could be brilliant.
It could be an amazing solution
to the problem we're solving.
I am not going to hear it,
because I don't give a crap
about where you learned it.
And what you're telling me,
whether you mean to or not,
is you don't give a crap about
where you're applying it.
Right?
So now, this could have all
happened in three months, six
months, whatever.
But look, the death
spiral's already begun.
And I have had no impact.
Totally unnecessary.
You still could have great
things to offer that we need.
And that's the one
thing we're missing.
So then, if I've
risen up, or I now
don't trust you to
handle my brilliance,
I'm going to start
to exert control.
So if I'm in a
managerial position,
and I fear I'm not having impact
and I'm being judged for it,
I'm going to exert control.
So my ability to let go
of decisions, my ability
to let go of
information, my ability
to let go of influence that
those I lead should have,
is now impaired, because
I fear if I let it go,
I'll be set up to fail.
What I'm not seeing is, you've
already begun to back away.
We all see that
back away, that sort
of virtual or physical
withdrawal of, OK, we
know where this is going to go.
I don't want to be anywhere
near it when it happens.
Maybe you've had
that experience.
Maybe you've been
on the receiving
end of being backed away from,
as a leader or a colleague,
from those who've decided
you're not a good fit.
So my ability to compress the
organization by making people
feel micromanaged,
distrusted, judged by me,
is now going to cause
frustration in the team
or the group or the colleagues,
among my colleagues.
They're going to
feel disempowered.
feel-- they're not
going to want to come to work.
When they get the
engagement survey,
I'm going to get dinged.
So even if I make
it for a full year,
I'm probably going to
get some feedback that
says, either there's early signs
that this is not working out,
or we're already past
it's not working out.
The other thing that happens
on the way up is that people--
the higher up in an organization
you go, the more longer-term
the result and impact you're
meant to have are, right?
So there's a little bit more
ambiguity and uncertainty
about what impact is defined as.
For somebody who's an individual
contributor or maybe even
a first-line manager,
impact can look
like the next few weeks or
months, or maybe, in your case,
probably hours.
But for somebody who, as you
move up, you're thinking,
hopefully, three, six,
nine, 12 months out,
which means there's a little
bit more uncertainty about how
those outcomes
will get achieved,
and the pathway to those
outcomes is not quite defined.
For some people, their need
for immediate gratification,
their need for immediate
impact, is such
that they can't tolerate that.
And so they struggle
with the uncertainty of,
how am I adding value if I can't
have an immediate line of sight
to that impact?
Because now my impact
is through you.
It's no longer at my own hands.
It's usually through others.
And for some people, that's
just a very difficult thing
to tolerate.
It's an orientation you
have to shift, to say,
I'm no longer the
smartest kid in the class.
My job is now to make other kids
the smartest kid in the class.
And if I've been rewarded
for a certain outcome
or a certain skill or
a certain deliverable
or a certain kind of
work for a long time,
and that's what I
pride myself on,
and now I have to
relinquish that in exchange
for other people doing that
and me enabling them to do it,
that's a--
what if it doesn't work?
Or what if people don't
recognize me for the ability
to have done that?
Or what if my impact
will be less visible now?
What if I can't tolerate that?
The good news is, if you
learn to tolerate it,
you're actually seen
as being a great leader
that everybody
wants to work for,
because people leave your
team and say, I learned a lot.
I grew a lot.
I made a great contribution.
And the last one we found
is a little bit more--
some of these are more prone,
or look a little different
when you come in from outside.
But when you come in from
up in the organization,
the problem is, my
guess is that if we
went back to hardware
and YouTube and support
and assistance,
all the divisions
you mentioned, and I
asked you to describe some
of the cultural realities
of your organizations,
I might hear some common
threads about Google's culture.
I might hear some differences.
But Google has a very
strong environment,
and there are things
you know about Google.
Well, the problem
is, your belief
that you know those
things causes you never
to test those assumptions.
So as you rise up, or as you
change groups and departments,
you bring what I
know with me, and you
see the world
through those biases,
without ever
understanding, well,
is that really how
it is in this group,
or how it is in
this team, or how it
is in this part of the world?
And so it's very important to
always test the assumptions
you have about what
you believe you
know, about where
you're arriving at,
because they know
things about you
as well that may
or may not be true.
And just as we don't want
to be labeled or concocted
in some way, neither do
the environments you have.
So how do you let
go of what you know
long enough to see
if all you know
is really all there is to know?
So those are just some
of-- there were probably--
there's certainly a bunch more.
So you can see, right,
any one of these
could take an otherwise
promising, gifted,
talented person and
send them off course.
All of them, avoidable.
With just the right
kind of preparation,
the right kind of
communication, the right kind
of conversations, nobody has
to step in these landmines.
But every day in
organizations, we're
throwing these things in the
way, and people are doing them.
But if you're lucky enough
to get to that place
and you arrive at
a new altitude,
then there are these--
you feel like you've
arrived on a new planet.
There's this disorienting
aspect of a higher altitude.
And these were
four of the things
we discovered that leaders
struggled to be OK with.
One of the problems is, when
you're leading other people,
especially if the people
you are leading are remote,
is there's now multiple
versions of you.
So you get this--
almost like your life
is now playing out
on the jumbotron.
And people are watching
you, and they're
making up versions of you.
I have leaders say to me all
the time, I hear all the time,
John said.
I never said it.
You have to assume that when
you become more influential
in an organization,
just assume there's
a megaphone strapped
to your mouth 24/7.
And everything you say
and do is amplified.
You can't raise your
eyebrow without somebody
attaching meaning to it.
Oh, she's in a bad mood today.
Or uh-oh, she just
came out of a meeting.
It didn't go well.
Or he's really frustrated
with something.
Could be nothing could be
further from the truth.
But we attach meaning
to our leaders--
their behavior, their
choices, their words,
how they act in meetings, all
has meaning, whether it's true
or not.
But we act upon it
as if it is true.
Leaders struggle
to know, what do I
do when people are making
things up about me,
or concocting versions
of me, that don't exist?
And there are ways to manage
that, but for many leaders,
it's paralyzing.
The third one was the
access to information.
So suddenly, people
who were my peers
are now my direct reports.
Suddenly the way I get
information, or access to it,
is a little different.
It feels a little filtered.
It feels a little
more sanitized.
It's not quite as honest.
And so how I get
people to tell me
the truth now becomes harder
and harder the higher I go,
because people don't want
to upset their bosses.
And so dealing with a little
bit of a sifted data set
becomes difficult when you're
trying to make hard choices
or make hard trade-offs
or allocate resources.
How we do that
becomes harder when
I don't know if the
information I'm being given--
did my mic just go off?
OK.
Should I wait?
Oh, there it is.
When I don't know that
I can rely on the data
that I'm getting.
And so how do I make
it safe, to make
sure the people that I work
with are telling me the truth?
How do I make it safe for
people to raise tough issues?
You are the company
case study for how
to create psychological
safety among teams.
So my guess is that if I
went around and polled you
on how psychologically
safe is your team, just
because the case study
was written about you
doesn't mean it's happening
everywhere at your company,
right?
So it's still a
difficult thing to do.
For leaders, when they
then have to wonder,
why aren't they
telling me the truth,
and what is the information
that I'm not getting,
and how am I getting access to
feedback, can be terrifying.
For some leaders,
that loss of control,
that sense of influence loss,
can be completely debilitating.
And lastly, the entire network
of relationships that shifts
can be very unsettling
for leaders.
So people who were your
peers are now direct reports.
People who were bosses
are now your peers.
People who were
direct reports before
don't interact with you at all.
And so what are the rules now?
What am I allowed to say?
What am I not allowed to say?
When you come to me saying, so,
you want to go out for beers?
And I'm like, well--
and then you get the whole,
oh, you're a boss now.
Right.
OK, never mind.
You get this very
passive-aggressive response
to you around, oh, so
you're one of them now.
OK, fine.
Or they try and say,
hey, you can tell me.
What's going on with XYZ?
Well, you know I
can't tell you that.
Well, why not?
It's me.
And there's this expectation
that the relationship really
hasn't changed.
So how you reset
all those boundaries
and keep a critical network
intact, for some leaders,
can just be frustrating
and confusing,
and they make two mistakes.
They do it extremely,
so they really
become a different person,
or they don't do it at all,
and they stay the buddy.
And then their ability
to exert authority,
their ability to make hard
decisions, their ability
to make decisions that
affect people that
don't want to be affected
by them is impaired later.
And so finding
the balance of how
to reset the boundaries while
keeping relationships intact
that are now different
is an art form.
And it can be done.
There are ways to do it.
But if no one says
to you, hey, you
need to go sit down
with the people who
used to be your peers
who now report to you
and have the following
conversation with them.
Or, you need to go sit
down with the people who
you used to report to
who are now peers to you
and have the following
conversation with them.
So that everybody goes, oh,
yeah, this is different now.
And now I know the new rules.
So those are just
some illustrative
looks at the landscape
on the way up,
and the landscape once you
land on the new planet.
Like I said before,
the great news
was there are predictable things
that those that actually stuck
the landing and
thrived did when they
landed that can be learned.
So these were the four things
that the exceptional leaders
did.
We call them choice, context,
connection, and breadth.
I'll talk about each
of them individually.
So breadth-- these
were the folks
that were able to move
out of a narrow swim lane,
their discipline, whether it was
a business unit or a functional
discipline like
finance or marketing,
and see the bigger picture.
They were able to understand how
the pieces of the organization
fit together.
They knew that it was really at
the seams of the organization
that actual transformation
and change happened.
So they can go from playing
first chair to conductor.
They could build
bridges between people.
If they grew up in finance,
they didn't see the world
economically.
Or if they grew up
in marketing, they
didn't see the world
through consumers.
If they grew up in YouTube,
they didn't see the world
through just video.
They could actually now
begin to broaden how
the organization came together.
The broader your influence
in an organization,
the more you have to bring
pieces together and see it
as a whole.
For some leaders who only
could stay in their swim lane
and see the world
through the lens
they came in with, struggled
to see how peripheral-- how
they fit into a bigger story.
These leaders instantly knew,
I fit into a bigger story here.
I should want to know
what that story is.
And they went and found out.
They were able to-- if there was
factions or conflict or border
wars among groups, they'd
bring those people together.
Rather than running
around and negotiating,
they would bring people
together to force them
into conversations that
built relationships.
So breadth, stitch
the seams around you.
Bring people together
in interconnection,
rather than letting
them be pulled apart.
Ask yourself, where are there
disconnects among the groups
I'm in or leading?
How do I bring them together?
For too many leaders,
the failure rate
was an issue of just ignoring.
They would aim their
influence at one group
at the expense of
others, and actually
make the division worse.
Context-- so these were the
leaders that were curious.
They came in and
started asking, what
is it I have to adapt about
my ideas or my approach
to fit in with this organization
just enough to be influential?
They didn't go native,
but they realized
that this environment has
as much to change in me as I
have to change in them.
So even if I thought
I had some mandate,
I didn't just go impose it.
I learned.
I adapted.
I read the tea leaves.
I asked myself outside,
what influences or trends
or technologies or
disruptions are coming my way?
What do I have to anticipate?
What could be unforeseen by me
now that I should know about?
They were innately
curious about the people
around them and the
business that they were in.
So in your case, ask
yourself, of all the ways
Google competes, what's
the actual contribution
and value my team creates?
I know what my tasks are.
I know what my deliverables are.
But how do I contribute
to the bigger story?
How do I fit into the
context of Google?
These leaders would start
with those questions.
The failed leaders
would start by assuming
the answer they
had was the answer
that everybody else needed.
And so being
brilliant, being smart
was more important to
them than learning.
So read the
environment around you.
And resist the need
to be constrained
by near-term results.
Actually set your sights
on longer-term-- learn,
as much as it is difficult when
other people are pressuring
you, to stay focused on
longer-term outcomes.
So choice-- turns
out decision-making
was a major impediment
for some leaders,
in terms of being able
to disappoint people.
Leadership is the ability
to disappoint people
at a rate they can absorb.
So if you're somebody
who says yes too much
because you want
to please people,
or you don't want to deal with
the rejection of people being
angry at you for disappointing
them, leadership will be hard.
But narrowing the
focus of a group--
how many of you have
ever said, or thought,
I have just enough priorities?
Nobody.
How many of you have said,
we have too many priorities?
Right?
We all feel overworked,
overstretched, unfocused.
So what's the alternative?
My only choice is,
OK, whatever you're
screaming about today,
that's what's important.
That's the priority.
Not, I'm clear on
the three things
that are the most critical.
The other things I can let go.
I know where to
make my trade-offs.
These leaders could
not only themselves,
but help those they lead,
make the hard trade-offs.
And they narrowed the focus of
the people to just a few things
to do them with excellence.
Nobody wants to come
to work and feel
like I get to do a bunch
of things mediocre.
But given the number of
priorities, or the urgent thing
de jour that you bring
up, I have no capacity
to understand what's
really important.
These leaders could
construct great choices.
They knew what data,
what intuition,
and what other voices
they should include
to construct a great decision.
They weren't overly
cowboy-like and independent,
and they weren't overly
false-consensus-driven,
where I want to
make sure everybody
feels included when I don't
really need to include them.
How many of you have ever
been in a meeting, or part
of a decision,
where you show up,
and the leader starts
talking about a decision
that you can already tell
they've already made?
We call that faux inclusion.
Those leaders get
found out, right?
So you're sitting
there thinking, really?
You're going to make me do
this fake dance with you?
Watched a-- a consumer
electronics CEO--
I was having a regular
check-in with him one day.
And his assistant buzzed him
and said, hey, Chad's here.
Do you want to see him?
And so he said yes, send him in.
I said, do you want
me to step out?
He said, no, no.
So in walks Chad, their IT
head, tattooed and pierced
everywhere.
And he walks up.
And I see my client,
Barry, pull out a file.
And I'm like, OK, this
is going to be boring.
So I just take out my phone,
and I start dissociating.
But I'm eavesdropping.
And Barry says, hey, I sent this
IT capital plan to the board.
Just want to make sure--
before I send it to
the board, I want
to make sure you're OK
with what I've committed
to for technology next year.
Well, I don't hear
Chad saying anything.
So I kind of peek up, and Chad's
got this really contorted look
on his face.
And he says, well,
I don't really
know what you're
asking me, Barry.
I know you already
signed off on that
and sent it to the
board yesterday.
So if you're asking me
to be OK with it, fine.
But don't ask my
opinion on something
you've already decided to do.
And he left.
And I could see Barry's
neck getting all red,
and he turns to me,
and he goes, do you
see the kind of disrespect?
I said, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Barry, what is it you
think just happened here?
I'm a CEO, [ANGRY NOISES].
I said, no, no, no, no.
Barry, my script
says you got caught.
He called you.
You were trying to pull
the wool over his eyes
to make him think he was part
of something he wasn't, and you
got caught for it.
My script says your
next line is, I'm sorry.
He gave you a gift.
He gave you the belief that
he trusted your relationship
enough to tell you the truth.
Your next move is to walk
down the hall and apologize,
not to be all up in
arms here, like--
you weren't the one
that got offended here.
He was.
And they went on to have
a great relationship.
But if you can't make the hard
choices honestly to the people
you have to make them to and let
the chips fall where they may,
leadership won't
be easy for you,
because sometimes
it means saying,
this is what needs to
be done, or no, we're
not going to do that, or
this needs to be done,
and I'm sorry it's going
to take some sacrifice.
We can't call that from our
people and model it ourselves.
Decision-making, especially
when your decisions
affect resources, priorities,
people's sense of importance,
how they spend
their time, how they
use their discretionary
influence,
if they feel jacked around,
your ability to be influential
is going to be impaired.
So this was a hard one.
One of the interesting things
we found about when people
had power in their
roles was that we
assumed we would find the
Harvey Weinsteins of the world.
You know, we'd find
people misusing power
for self-gain and self-interest
and immoral reasons.
They were there.
That was not nearly
the abuse of power
as much as it was
people abandoning power.
People were too
afraid to use it.
They let go of it.
And we need to see
that as as much
of an abuse of power
as self-interest,
is self-protection.
If you're too uncomfortable
using power, don't take it.
But if you can't exercise
power to make things
more just, to make
things more fair,
to make things more
clear, to make things
more compelling for people,
then decision-making
will be a struggle.
And the last dimension
was connection.
So these were the people
everybody wanted to work for.
So how many of you have leaders
that you have seen this--
there's the " I could
work for her or him" boss?
Right.
So it's those people.
So they're trustworthy.
They're compelling.
They're credible.
They're respected.
But one of the major
differentiators
was that everybody
believed that they
were out to make other
people successful,
that the thing on their
agenda highest in relationship
was, how do I help you succeed?
One guy in our study said he
asks everybody three questions.
He asks first, what can
I do to improve to be
a better colleague to you?
Second, what are you working
on that's really important?
And three, what can I do to help
you with that really important
thing?
And for a decade, this was his
mantra, and everybody knew it.
And everybody knew he meant it.
And so the interesting
differentiator was,
I didn't build my
stakeholder network
and focus on relationships that
I could get something from.
I focused on building
relationships with--
and this is peers, direct
reports, and bosses, all 360.
How do I make other
people successful?
Not politically, but
because I genuinely
enjoyed watching
other people thrive.
I genuinely enjoyed watching
how I make other people soar.
And this was innate to
who these folks were.
And that's how they maintained
their relationships,
and that's how they built
credibility and respect.
So you can see, breadth,
context, choice,
connection-- they're four
really powerful and big muscles,
and why it was
hard to say you've
got to be good at all four.
But if you want to succeed and
be influential on the way up
and navigate those
landmines on the way up
and navigate the
disorientation of being higher,
you can learn these now.
For context, start
asking questions around
how you can adapt more to
the environment you're in.
For breadth, ask, what
seams can I bridge?
What seams do I sit at that
I can connect better to?
For choice, ask yourself, how
comfortable am I saying no?
How comfortable am I
disappointing somebody
for the right thing?
And for connection,
ask yourself,
do the people in your
network understand
you to be somebody who is
out to make them successful?
If somebody went and asked
on your behalf, what's
it like to work with you,
would they say, oh, yeah,
they have my back?
So you can start now to
build these capabilities
and layer them into
your leadership
so that as you become more
influential, and one day when
you're a CEO of Google or a
CEO of some other company here,
you can have the impact you want
to have and make the difference
you want to make
and be successful.
So, thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
And so we'll do Q&A. We have
time for some questions.
So what do you want
to know more about?
And there's a microphone
in the corner there.
So please go use that
microphone to ask your question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I actually-- first of all,
thank you very much for coming.
This is fantastic.
RON CARUCCI: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I actually
have two questions.
The first is, I guess
I was a little confused
between how to distinguish
between the context
source of power and the
breadth source of power.
They both seem to
be about having
an understanding of the bigger
picture and elaborating there.
So I was hoping you
could elaborate on sort
of what makes those unique.
RON CARUCCI: Great questions.
Context is depth.
So it's deep.
And breadth is wide.
So context is about what's
happening right now, in front
of me, that I need to adapt to.
Breadth is the puzzle,
so all the puzzle pieces
and how they fit together.
So if I'm in YouTube,
where does YouTube
fit into the broader
Google strategy?
What's the bigger
story we're a part of?
Context is, what's Vimeo doing
that I need to care about
right now in my job?
AUDIENCE: Got it.
And having both simultaneously
will allow you to traverse.
RON CARUCCI: Yes.
And so that's a great point.
It's all four of
them simultaneous,
because for me to act
upon that question,
I have to have the
relationships to do it.
I have to make the hard
choices to make it happen.
So this is one thing with
four parts, not four things.
That's what makes it tricky.
AUDIENCE: And I guess
the second question is,
you mentioned earlier on about
all the different pitfalls,
and those who had established
poor relationships.
If somebody has
walked down that path
and has sort of a negative
reputation preceding them,
in your experience, are
they able to turn it
around by learning the skills?
Or should they be moving
into greener pastures?
RON CARUCCI: That's
a great question.
Yes, they can.
And if you're in
the same environment
that you already
expect people to be
looking at you a certain way,
you have to confront that.
You have to say, I
understand you all
see me from this experience.
I'm asking you not to.
And I'm asking you to let
me earn my right to regain
your trust and respect.
If I don't do that,
I want to be told,
but I want to be innocent
until proven guilty.
So can you give me the
suspension of disbelief
and allow me to succeed here?
And you have to ask for it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
Would you mind sharing
some of the things
that you found either
most surprising
or that seem to be
most counterintuitive
about your research?
RON CARUCCI: Great question.
Thank you.
The power thing really
took us off guard,
that the biggest abuse
of it was abandoning it,
that people are more
cowardice than they are--
can I say "asshole"-- assholes.
We have those,
but they're just--
and sometimes the
reason for the cowardice
was so that I avoid
being seen as a jerk.
But you took the job.
You have all these C letters
next to your name now.
But I think people are
not trained to understand
that power is a great thing.
You don't have to be
self-indulgent with it.
But you have the ability
to create justice.
You can take things that
are not fair or not right
and make them right.
And that should be
exciting to you.
So that surprised me, because
why would you want the job?
The other thing that surprised
us that I didn't like--
I told you this
before-- was I hated
that you had to be good
at all four of these,
because I don't feel
good at all four of them.
So I didn't feel good about
telling others to do it.
And so I really
wanted it to be true
that the good ones who rise
up could do three of the four,
at least, and have a couple
of rough edges on one of them.
And the truth is,
some of us do, right?
The other thing that
surprised me was--
anybody here from HR?
I'm gonna say [INAUDIBLE],,
but I'll pretend.
So, so many of the devices
of the early failure issues
are HR processes.
Selection, reward,
development, all the--
and I was surprised
because I come out of HR.
At some point in my
career, I spent time there.
I was surprised that--
we could fix them.
Why aren't we fixing them?
So I was frustrated and
exasperated by that.
Thanks for the question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I
just had a question.
Did the research
suggest that people
were self-aware of their gaps
in these four dimensions?
Or was it sort of like
they didn't realize it
until after they had completely
failed, and that sort of thing?
RON CARUCCI: I so wish I could
answer the question with yes,
they were.
But they weren't.
So that young man
who I told you I
got the phone call about,
his failure was context.
He had a failure of
just not reading the tea
leaves around him.
He got so overwhelmed with
the complexity of his job,
he just ignored it--
not because he couldn't have
learned it, because no one
told him to.
And so it was usually, to
your question, after the fact.
And so often, so
many of them-- when
we talked to some of
the failure cases,
over and over, why
didn't someone tell me?
If I had known they
were frustrated
with my frustration
with them because they
weren't taking my good
idea, I could have changed.
People just backed away
and didn't say anything.
I tell leaders all the time,
if you went to a dinner party
with a significant other and
you decided to leave early,
and your significant other
turns to you in the car
and says, honey, you have
a big thing hanging off
the end of your nose.
Get it off.
It's been there all night.
What might your question be?
You tell me now?
We all have Things hanging
off our behavior we can't see.
Get in on the conversation.
You should want to know.
And so you should always be
asking, how can I do better?
What am I doing
that frustrates you?
What can I improve?
If you just ask
for the feedback--
and don't wait
until it's too late.
You can ask today.
You can leave here
today, go to somebody,
and say, what's the thing
we're talking about on my nose
that no one's telling me about?
And find a colleague that's
honest enough to tell you.
SPEAKER 1: All right,
Rob, we've got a question
from the livestream audience.
RON CARUCCI: Oh, cool.
SPEAKER 1: So the
question is around,
how do you get businesspeople
who are the agents of change
here to actually abide
by these recommendations?
RON CARUCCI: Give
them my phone number.
I would love to have
a chat with them.
You know, here's the
painful question.
If you don't look
at these four--
so we were very
humbled and honored
that "HBR" named this as one
of the ideas that mattered most
in 2016.
When we published this research,
we had hundreds of thousands--
our website was almost crashing,
because people were like, yes!
But if you don't recognize the
self-evident obviousness of,
yes, that's what
I should do, then
you don't believe it, right?
But the question I would ask
is, OK, so if it's not these,
then what?
If you don't think that these
are the standards of being
able to be influential,
2,700 people in the study
wasn't enough, OK, I'll
suspend my disbelief.
You tell me what they are.
You tell me, what are
the success factors
that you want to abide by or
apply to your own behavior
or pursue to be successful?
And then show me who else has
been successful with them.
That's what I would ask.
But otherwise, my
question would be,
if you're rising
up with influence
and you're rising up to want
to have broader change, what
standards are you using?
If you're making it up as
you go, if you're thinking,
I'm all that and a bag of
chips and I've already arrived
and I have what I
need, you're dangerous.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
What recommendations do
you have for seeking out
mentorship and coaching?
RON CARUCCI: Do it.
So it's a very
personal issue, right?
So you want a relationship
that's mutually beneficial.
You don't want someone to
clone themselves in you.
And I think those
are different--
I think mentorship
is a much more
intimate, ongoing relationship.
Coaching should
start with feedback.
If you're going to
hire a coach, please
make sure they're
trained and certified
and not somebody
who somebody said,
hey, you give good advice!
You should be a coach!
They all hang shingles out.
It's bad.
The industry has become this--
it's terrible.
There's people out there
just dispensing advice
because someone told them--
their mother told them,
you're so smart!
So make sure somebody has
got some clinical training
and some behavioral
science training
and knows what they're
coaching you in.
And get feedback.
I hired a coach two
years ago for me.
And people were like, at
this point in your career?
You probably think
it's too late.
But it's never too late.
And all I have
thought for two years
was, why did I wait so long?
Help is so good.
I mean, none of us
can do this alone.
And if you think you can,
please don't lead anybody.
So the idea of getting help,
and having somebody-- we
are notoriously bad
observers of our own reality.
We don't have good third eyes.
So having another
set of eyes on you
and how you function
in the world
and how others experience you,
even if you have people getting
in your face and
being honest, still,
to have an objective
third party tell you,
here's who you are to the world.
Now, if that's not what you
want to be to the world,
here's how you can change that.
What a gift!
And the earlier you
do it, the better.
I tell every one of my clients
who run big departments
or companies, I want--
you have to have--
I want to be your
coach, and I want
the name of your therapist,
your personal trainer,
and your nutritionist.
There's a foursome there.
You should not be
running tens of thousands
of people and
billions of dollars
of budgets without at least,
if not more, those four things
around you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks for coming.
According to the study,
a majority of people
didn't have all four,
hence the failure rate.
For the people who
have three out of four,
was there a normal
distribution, or did
you see that one particular
quadrant was just
really hard for people to--
RON CARUCCI: Such
a great question.
So context and connection
caused faster failure.
So in the 18-month window,
the six-month failures
were all failures of connection.
And specifically, peers
and direct reports
could pull the plug on your
career quicker than anybody.
Bosses were a little
bit out of sight.
Context was you're
obtuse, right?
The interesting thing
about choice and breadth
was the failures came
later, because here's why.
So if your company
sucks at decision-making
and your governance
structures are unclear
and it's either all false
consensus or all cowboy,
you'll blend right in.
People won't know you
suck at decision-making.
And if your company
sucks at breadth,
meaning it's very fragmented,
very siloed, and very
individualistic and
very piecemealed,
you'll fit right in.
The problem becomes after you're
trying to fight that, right?
So if you're trying to introduce
better decision-making,
because you're good
at it and they're not,
or you're trying to bridge
the seams and you get resisted
and no one else is on that same
mission, you fail, but slower.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
I'd love to hear
some of your thoughts
on how to build trust
and relationship to get
some of that honest
feedback, beyond just asking.
How do you actually
get the real answer?
RON CARUCCI: So you have
to commit to other people's
success, right?
And find a couple of people,
find a couple of peer coaches,
or get a small group
together and say, hey, can we
have each other's backs here?
And there are some
great tools out there.
Come to our website.
We've got some great
tools to offer on,
how are we going to learn
to give each other feedback?
And how are we going to learn
to-- so in this meeting,
I'm about to give
this presentation.
Or, in this meeting,
I'm about to go do this.
Can you watch for
the following things?
It takes courage to ask.
But if you find people
with whom you have--
the colleagues.
If you don't have the
trust there, then ask them,
what would it take for us,
over the next few months,
to build the kind of
trust with each other?
And just say, I've
observed your insights.
You seem someone who
has a lot to offer.
I'd love your feedback.
And I recognize that
maybe right now we
don't have that relationship.
But how, over the next
90 days, can we do that?
Lunch once a week?
But be intentional about it.
And people appreciate that.
But be very-- those
relationships are made, not
born.
Yeah.
Guys, thanks so
much for having me.
It's been great to be with you.
Enjoy your holiday.
[APPLAUSE]